this was not hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you I'm Eddie your host
you're watching the Deen show and for
those of you who have been keeping up
with us we've been talking about
marriage keeping it together something
that's very important that you find a
good spouse and you get married you try
to stay together and we mentioned that
broken homes lead to broken society so
we cover it on marriage and we're
getting some advice from Sheikh Abu Toba
when we come back we've if you didn't
see the other parts of the episodes go
to the Deen show com look for Abu Tobi's
special section there so you can kind of
catch up to where we're at today we're
going to continue on given advice for
those who are married and even those who
aren't married who are thinking about
getting married well we know that this
is half your Deen so you need to race to
get married but the right spouse and
we're going to be getting more of this
advice and also going to touch upon
divorce if it leads to that you come in
peace you leave in peace the proper way
when we come back here on the Dean show
sit tight I'm going away this is the
Dean the Dean
this is the thing
this is the thing is just enjoy this is
the thing
so I'll they can peace be with us and I
want to like get back again on the Dean
show thank you for finding time to be
with us people you have your own section
there at the Dean show my own section
yes and we've done a lot of shows before
a few if people go back there to catch
up we're kind of doing a family series
but give me some advice now just to kind
of recap we talked about the importance
of keeping the family together the
family structure the the man's role he's
the person that Allah just like you have
one God one creator who's maintaining
sustain in his whole universe you have
one leader in the house you have like
well we made the analogy of the pilot
the copilot so the man who's leading the
house and the woman he's being extra
kind we talked about extra kind to the
wife giving her her rights and the woman
also having to acknowledge that he's the
one that God Almighty put in charge and
listening to him obviously in the
obedience to a law and then we so just
recap we can recap and then we'll go
into this host family structure the
family business doesn't work then we got
to leave in peace as we came in peace
right that's the divorce now how little
of it will be allowed I mean like you
said the first things that have to be
established a long time ago I remember
when I first got married I me and my
wife we were arguing and Suraj will Hajj
we bumped into him we went around a
corner we ran right into Suraj Imams
rajma Hajj how feather hula and he saw
us arguing and he looked down on us as
fatherly and uncle II eyes and he said
don't ask for your rights until first
you fulfill all your obligations and
then he told my wife the same thing and
that lasted that piece of advice that
lasted about ten years of our marriage
and even then more so after it the
important thing before you go to divorce
is that you look to see that you've
tried your best to fulfill the
obligations that you have upon your
spouse but as what we find in divorce is
most of the people saying Mimi
me the the ego gets involved and they've
decided that instead of trying to fix it
some people want to destroy it but what
the proper thing to do is as Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala tells us to to keep
her in kindness and to let her go in
kindness this shows that this is on the
part of the husband okay I can't stress
it enough that the major thing the
husband has to do is be kind be kind to
your wife what does that mean that
doesn't mean that you spoil your wife
and give her everything that she wants
to that she wants when you're trying to
do things cuz something she asked you to
do may be wrong we have the ayat in the
Quran where Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
tells us that sometimes your wives and
your children can be under one luckam
can be enemies for you for Haru so take
your precautions against them and this
is in reference to even a bass explains
to us some men some mekin men who
accepted Islam in the early days but
they never made Hitler why didn't they
make Hitler because their families their
wives and their children said oh you
know they're having fights over there
there's there's you know it's gonna be
harder for us we're doing so well over
here economically so they didn't make
the hitter and when they finally did go
they saw that other people who had
accepted Islam after them and the
initial stages didn't know as much as
they had had made such great leaps and
bounds and their Deen and left them
behind that they wanted to punish their
families for making up for this type of
thing but Allah revealed in the Quran
that you should forgive them and wipe it
away and he is gonna forward or Rahim so
it shows that the man has to understand
two things from this iron that sometimes
the decisions that his wife and his
children one of the make may be wrong
and this may be actually a form of
animosity and enemies to him so he has
to make the decisions but at the same
time he has to be nice to them and kind
to them in the whole interaction and
forgive them for their mistakes the
things that they make so if it comes
down to divorce Allah says in the Quran
original Kauai muna Island Nisa that the
men are the maintainer and the providers
and protectors of the women this is
in the marriage and during the divorce
as well and a lot else in the Quran well
that the men wanna burn every Jala
hymnody Raja and the men have over the
ladies a degree what is this degree
again if it Abasi defines for us that
the degree that the men have over the
ladies is that even though the ladies
cannot fulfill all the rights the men
have because even though the woman have
more rights the man's one right right to
be obeyed it's such a great right that
the prophets on our cell have said if I
were to make anyone prostrate in front
of them before someone else it would be
that the woman prostrate to man but
that's not the way it is this what I
need it's only for allah subhanahu wa
tada why are we mentioning this the
degree is that the man even though he
knows the woman can't give him his
rights he's going to give her and
fulfill her rights he's going to look
out for her and make sure that she gets
everything that she has coming the
Prophet said marry your daughters to
those men who have taqwa mcduck Dean why
because if they love them then that's
good and there'll be love spread amongst
the Ummah and if he doesn't like her at
least because of his taqwa he'll give
her her rights what are her rights and
divorce as I said the men of the
maintain is and provide us for the women
so maybe when we come back we can talk
about what how exactly the man gives the
woman her rights with regards to divorce
everything is laid out there is work no
is no it's not up for you to decide it's
not up for me to decide it's not up for
anybody to do their own thing it's
straightening out the woman's rights and
the man's obligations the man's rights
and the woman's obligations so just the
worst same way you don't do jumping
jacks and you know and worship God your
own way God has a system the same way we
make prostration we go into all the
different rituals
everything's been laid out all that is
there the same way for marriage divorce
getting together all this is there in
Islam but you know the only reason I
don't want to start on it because you
know what I wanted to do though each
piece of it everybody's okay alright no
guess where thats what i want to leave
off everything is there in islam yes
okay we'll be right back with more here
on the deed show do you think these
things are going to bring you happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain is really what we are offering
in Islam what we have found in Islam for
ourselves is a means by which our hearts
are in peace they're at rest they're not
discontent we are pleased with what we
have
those back here on the Dean show and
we're getting into now divorce okay you
tried everything and things just saying
working out so you have this right to
part ways okay you know you haven't
tried everything just yet okay okay but
most people think that they have tried
everything in there at their wit's end
where to go the problem that we have
here in the you know in the West I
should say is that most people do these
divorces at home by themselves and it
causes a lot of confusion they don't
usually know what or exactly how to do
it they read the books and they say hey
divorced three times
so they just starts screaming divorced
your divorce I can't stand you you know
I'm out of here and then this is not a
divorce in Islam the first thing the man
has to do when he fears disloyalty from
his wife when he fears that his wife is
not it was going to what we call a state
of in the shoes and this is saying on
the part of the man because divorce is
only in the hands of the man it's not in
the hands of the woman the woman can ask
for a hula but it's still up to the man
whether the granted or not and I'm
telling everybody all the different
emails out there do not go so quick to
grant these ladies a hula this is the
advice that we get from our teachers our
professors are she you you know not to
allow the Westerners to get these quick
fix call us these annulments because
these annulments are happening is become
a fad nowadays every lady learns now
that she can have a color she gets a
quick fix color it's over and you're
going about your business no that's not
the purpose for it so we're advising the
amounts not to be so quick and doing
this and the ladies to be careful even
about asking of it because the profits
of myself said that any woman who asked
for a whole hour divorce from her
husband without having a good reason
then she will not find the scent of
Jenna and the scent of Jenna goes for a
period of time and some people say that
forty years a distance of travel of 40
years the scent of Jenna can be found in
Allah knows best but this just shows the
grave you know problem or challenge that
is for the person who asked for a hula
or divorce and they don't deserve it
what's going to happen to them so that's
one thing so divorce is only in the hand
of the man so we go to the thing why do
men
why do men divorce a woman just looking
at the best situation meaning that the
man is a good man and a woman is a good
woman right not going to these extremes
then what has happened in the emotional
bank account of a person everybody has
an emotional bank account right I have
an emotional bank account with you you
have one with me the difference with men
is men give points and they take points
away so if I bring you a pie
some of Emmys cookies or something like
that you say well abu talib brought me
some pies all the way from the other
side of the country I'm going to give
him a hundred points in my emotional
bank account right but if I come and I
say and I do something rude you can say
well Bert Apple was rude let me take ten
points off or 100 points off out of my
emotional bank account whereas women
they only count by one so if you get the
cake or you get the diamond ring you're
only going to get one point men count by
the level of difficulty
that's difference women don't take away
points when men take away points this is
important because this distinguishes the
difference between why men can call the
divorce and why women cannot when a man
has zero in his emotional bank account
for his wife or he feels she's in the
negative okay in the red and she's not
making enough points to get even even
now he decides he wants to divorce her
so then he has to first first and
foremost give his wife a good lecture he
has to talk to it doesn't mean that he
sits there laboriously and points his
fingers uuuuu nope but s have some game
you have to have some flavor he has to
talk to his wife in a way that would
make her understand if he can that she
has done something that this pleases him
it may not even be wrong but it may be
something that he doesn't like and he
doesn't want to happen in his household
and he has that right to do that if he
can get his wife to understand what he
wants her to do and she returns back to
being his wife and this goes into a
longer conversation as to the role of
women in a society you know the women
are supposedly dead
helpers so a man gets married to wife so
she can help him in his life now if she
doesn't want to do that then she doesn't
want to be a wife you know and we have
this big egotistical thing here in the
West where it's like both of us are
fighting and vying for the attention
when in actuality there is a role for
everyone the father is the husband is
the lead the woman is the supporting
person the supporting lead in our he is
the one that comes and says what he
wants she's the one that gets it done
the manager of the house he can say what
he wants and she if he wants mots and
she likes Heights she has to get mots
you know and it is his way and it's not
him being a big baby to do that so if
she doesn't want to do that you know
then he could say okay you know what I'm
gonna separate beds with you now he
stops having sleeping with the lady in
her bedroom does that mean he goes and
doesn't come home
no he separates bed with her in fact the
rule is that she's supposed to get out
of the bed but most women won't do that
he sleeps in his bed says no you don't
sleep in my bed tonight you sleep in
over here and you makes a nice little
palette for her or a pullout bed right
next to the bed or if she decides I'm
not getting out of the bed and most
women said I'm getting out the bed you
get out of the bed then he can turn the
other way and sleep across the bed at
the bottom or he can get out the bed and
sleep on the floor he should not leave
the room he should go ahead and sleep on
the floor but not leave the room and I
know ladies think it's funny but it's
his bed it's his bed and again this goes
back to the point that the man is doing
his job meaning that he's providing for
his family if he's providing for his
family then it is his bed and if his
wife is helping in that then there's
going to be a problem because whenever
the economics are mixed then it's not
clear of whose property it is you know
the man should make sure that he
provides everything he can for his
family to avoid confusion okay so now he
stops sleeping with her but this is only
in the bedroom the children should know
the neighbors should know this shouldn't
be something that's public knowledge
everybody in the masjid is talking about
it she's on the floor on the phone
talking to her friends he's on the phone
talking to his friends and their
business is being played out in the
street this is just gonna cause jealousy
this is just gonna cause people to give
them the evil eye this is gonna cause
the shaitaan to get involved into
further sour their situation how about
the mother-in-law the close sister now
the mother and the family members even
them they shouldn't be getting involved
it depends on the family member that's
to the discretion of the husband yeah
all that Rabab because remember a woman
is bound to obey her husband and she is
alabaster level level and he is
alabaster aha
he is a covering for her so if he
doesn't want his business spread out to
his other relatives then she doesn't
have a right to do that now she does
have a right to seek Islamic knowledge
meaning that if she doesn't understand
something she can call or get in touch
with an imam a knowledgeable person that
he respects she has to go to someone
that he respects it's not gonna work if
she goes to someone she respects and he
doesn't respect that person and if he
doesn't respect anyone then that's his
fault you know but she should go to
someone that he respects to ask what her
rights are and what she should do next
and this regard and she should maybe
call his father as we see in the hadith
of The Messenger of Allah one of the
wives of one of the Sahaba was having a
problem with her husband he was not
sleeping with her he was praying all
night and fasting all day she went to
his father and complained to his father
about the situation when the father came
by and asked how are you doing she
explained to him in clear terms that her
son what a good son he is but he's not
sleeping with me he's praying all night
and he's fasting all day so the father
understood that and took it to the
Messenger of Allah someone I sell them
and clarify how the son should behave so
then that's why we say that you know but
the man has a right to have be obeyed in
his house you know and if the woman is
going to say she wants to be treated
like a woman and she has to behave like
a woman and not be like equal to a man
to try to fight him and become physical
with him and I'm always suggesting a
woman don't hit your husband and then
when your husband hit back you call me
and say oh he hit me don't hit no one
should hit okay no if you don't hit men
you don't get hit and we're not talking
about those women that get abused by men
those men are clearly wrong we're
talking about when it's going both ways
and then the woman try to phase it like
he is the abusive type okay
alhamdulillah the next step then is if
he's so tired of his wife
he doesn't want to marry the Meritor
anymore then what they should do is get
a hack amendment aleihi muhammad
Montagna
then they should go and get advice from
one person from her family one person
from his family it doesn't have to be a
family member it could be anyone that
they feel is knowledgeable enough and
strong enough and respected enough to
listen to your side or her side and
articulate that between the two how come
in the two judges between them and at
the same time if there's those two
people
well the respected or not don't have
islamic knowledge then they should
introduce the third person the imam or
the scholar to listen to what they come
up with and talk to those two people
outside of the two married people the
husband and wife and they should then
decide what should be the next steps if
the next step is that the husband should
take some advice and do what stoke and
the husband is bound to do what he's
told you know if this wife has to change
then the wife is bound to do what she's
told if it decided that both of them are
stubborn they're not gonna do what we
tell them to do or this is not gonna
solve the issue we moved it to the next
stage the next stage is that the husband
divorced the wife how is the divorce
going to happen first thing he has to do
we said he stopped sleeping with her
what this means now he cannot call the
first cry of divorce until after he has
stopped to have an intercourse with his
wife she has her menses okay and then
she comes off her menses and now she's
clean from her menses and he hasn't had
sexual intercourse with her since she's
been clean from her menses so it's clear
she's not pregnant
at this time he can name divorce honor
he can say I divorced you or any wording
that would be clear that he's through
and they're no longer going to be
married
the Imam should then be brought in and
informed that you divorced your wife
this person divorced his wife why
because when you do it in private it's
not there's no clarity now we bring two
witnesses the Imam is the main witness
here and he may choose him or I then
well another person in her family or his
family like his father or her father or
her brother another male to witness the
fact
it doesn't have to be physically there
it can be done throughout the phone then
I always suggest that you talk to the
wife and say wife do you understand that
your husband has divorced you yes he
does we make clarity all right now he's
divorced her that's the first type of
divorce when that is their divorce is
not over the rule with us as teachers as
as family counselors is a tow feet
create a minute to freak this is the
general rule
keeping the families together is more
important and better than separating
them so we find every route possible to
try to keep the family together so some
people say or we don't answer all the
emails all the emails about marriage we
answer we get because that is very
important you know the family is the
main structure of the society and as you
stated so eloquently unhealthy family
unhealthy society broken family busted
society okay so we want to make sure
that the the marriage is does everything
that we can to keep the family together
so we start to do more intervention we
always asked the people to read certain
books certain literature that we suggest
sometimes the people get stubborn say
well this is not an Islamic book but the
Prophet SAW I saw them said knowledge is
the laws or beneficial things or the
lost item of the believer wherever he
finds that he picks it up now she has to
wait the doctor or son Arthur took kuru
what is that it's a term in Arabic that
could mean the pure part time which is
not on her menses or it could mean the
time that she's on her menses it's again
up to the discretion of the scholar the
Eman not the husband for the Imam if
he's on the interpretation that it's
three periods now the three periods
start even though he divorced her after
she was clear one month that's not
counted when she has the next menses
that's considered one then the second
menses that's considered - the third one
that's considered Kanuri some those who
consider the coudl her menses those that
consider the pure period her menses now
it takes a longer period time she has a
menses she comes off that's one she has
a message she comes off that's - she has
MS it comes up that's three okay so then
it's the
how that Imam is deciding to count how
she's president which could drag out to
five months it could even take a lot
longer if the woman is irregular in her
menses because just because she's a
regular and doesn't have her menses
every month or something like that
doesn't mean that we rush we still wait
this she could be pregnant and if she's
pregnant then the the period of her her
egg that we call this that his waiting
period and the waiting period has to be
explained as well but if she's pregnant
the waiting period is not just until she
gives birth but when she's finished
giving her postpartum bleeding okay when
she finishes giving her a postpartum
bleeding okay so the egg duck period
this period should be done in the home
the wife does okay I'm the boss well I'm
leaving I'm going back to my mother's
house
no she doesn't leave she can't go
anywhere she stays in the home and he
doesn't leave either they are forced to
be under the same circumstances why
because then that might lead to mine we
said at Offutt it might lead them to
come back together he's mad at her right
now but then when he sees her in her
lingerie he falls in love with her and
remembers why he wants to be with her
the Prophet SAW said you don't like
dislikes something in a believing lady
accepted there's something else that you
like about her okay so you may not like
the fact that she said something fouled
to you but then you miss Allah you
forgot an ayah and she recites that iron
reminds it to you and you remember that
you love her Deen and she remembered
that iron she reminded you you may want
to stay together just because of that or
because you can't decide who gets the
cat you know we had a situation some
people who they didn't they wanted to
get divorce but they couldn't decide who
gets the cat so they stayed together so
whatever the thing is that we can find
to keep the people together they stay
together so they're in the home together
they have to sleep in the same bedroom
if they want to separate the beds we
can't force them isn't that we don't
have any control but we want them to
sleep in the same bed with each other
perhaps that might encourage them to
stay married anything that would make
them break the ada breaks the ADA he can
kiss her on the cheek and say you know I
love you
you know you know I'm sorry I'm gonna
want to divorce you who you could say
you're not divorced anymore he doesn't
even have to say anything if he can head
under snake her understand that he's not
going to divorce her
the that is broken and they're no longer
divorced and we try to do anything that
we can do to keep the people together
okay let's take a break and we'll
continue more with this very important
topic here in the Dean show it's your
type of right back okay from a science
major when you look at the Bible says
the earth has four corners the that's
wrong if any Christian can point out a
single unaccomplished issue a single
unambiguous treatment where Jesus Christ
peace be upon him says say that I am God
always worshipped me I am rhetorics of
Christianity
back here on the Dean show and we're
gonna have to cut short we just want to
wrap it up now because I mean these are
long topics but we just want to
stimulate people that you know what the
same way that you go to a doctor when
you have an ailment you have a disease
you know you don't mix some formula
together and the chemicals and then you
just experiment we have the verbatim
Word of God the Quran and we have the
authentic sayings at last the final
messenger everything is there and
scholars people such as yourself who
deduce everything from the divine
guidance and we have everything it's
clear we don't have to go guesswork we
don't have to go to the coffee shop and
get advice I don't go to have to go to
the water fountain water fountain we can
come straight to people such as yourself
and the teachers because isn't it true
that the the prophets didn't leave money
or well but they left the knowledge
right yes it's true so we want to sit
with people of knowledge so summarize
everything in this last minute that we
have on this topic well you know it's a
very difficult topic to summarize in one
word or in a minute so like you said we
have the people that like okay we have a
website admin at the fixed dot or or the
my fix org and on that website we
provide marital counseling people are in
a rush to break up a marriage marriage
is one of the most important
institutions in Islam the Prophet salah
salem said it is the most important
contract you can make after the Shahada
because afterward you know ladies become
lawful for you and by the word of a law
so we want to make sure that we
fulfilled that thing if someone has some
marital problems they can contact us if
someone wants to learn about how to get
married they can contact us at the fix
or call my fixed org or check us out on
the web and we'll help them through the
long route of marriage oh you know a
collusion thank you very much thank you
to you for being with us we got almighty
Lord you thank you so much thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Deen
show marriage is so important it's so
important it's half your Deen you find
that right spouse husband or wife and
now you want to make sure that you're
living according to the guidelines
there's no guesswork everything is there
you're extra kind to your wife and why
is you respect your husband you respect
each other then you live in peace and
harmony and that's
you get the tranquility within each
other try to avoid all this this
unnecessary discourse unnecessary
argumentation you know try to really
adhere adhere to the Quran adhere to the
guidelines that the last and final
messenger peace be upon him he told us
to adhere to but you got to get the
knowledge you got to seek the knowledge
and live it so you could be successful
in this life and definitely in the next
general paradises we're striving for
it's life is short it can end at any
time and we want to get to Jenna that's
the ultimate prize until next time peace
be unto you
who
Oh show us the way to illustrate this is
the D did